California man is accused of raping or
sexually assaulting seven women in a
case that raises new questions about the
safety of ride-sharing services like
uber and lyft 44 year old Nicholas
Morales faces 27 felony counts police
say that he posed as a rideshare driver
Carter Evans shows us the risk and the
new technology that companies are using
to try to keep the passenger safe ride
share services like uber and lyft are
often used as a safe way home after a
night out but a series of sexual
assaults by men posing as drivers is
prompting police to warn passengers to
take extra precautions certainly reminds
us that you know there are a lot of bad
people out there the Los Angeles
District Attorney's Office says Nicholas
Morales attacked at least seven
different women while posing as a
rideshare driver he's facing more than
two dozen charges including rape and
sodomy by use of force our victim was
preoccupied at the time thought that she
was getting into the vehicle that was
there to pick her up mr. Morales took
advantage of the situation and the
salted her police say predators are
taking advantage of these apps because
their victims are looking for regular
cars not well marked taxicabs Tracy
Breeden who manages global safety
communications for uber says their app
has several safeguards to help
passengers so we have the license plate
right here and we have the make in the
model of the vehicle as well as the
picture of the driver
Breeden says another key step is asking
the right question as you approach the
car hi can you tell me who your here is
here for Tracy so he said the right name
uber is also currently inviting drivers
in select markets to install uber beacon
it's a digital display that allows
passengers to match the color that
appears on their amp with the color in
the car lyft has similar features riders
say these attacks are a good reminder to
stay alert I should probably do more
it's just so much part of the culture
especially living in the city that
I don't think about it anymore for CBS
this morning Carter Evans San Francisco
well we reached out to the Los Angeles
County Public Defender's Office which is
representing Morales they were unable to
comment overnight another note make sure
you checked before you get in the car
and safe